so this last week I've been pretty m.i.a
because of uh we do our annual
leadership retreat with the company I've
been doing this town for five years and
I ran out of crazy place and this time
around I rented out the bcbg founders
place that's a 1.2 million dollar
chandelier behind me just look at some
of this stuff this guy did creative what
a creative guy okay
this house is right now on sale that's
the ceiling imagine that that's the
ceiling one of the rooms stood 17
bedrooms 30 plus thousand square feet
I'll show you what the back looks like
but we come here every year and it's
three and a half days of me speaking and
strategizing with these guys for 12
straight hours I've probably spoken I
don't know 40 hours in the last three
and a half days with these guys and
there's something I did very different
this time rod okay when we had this
session usually we'll go through a lot
of data a lot of data and we did we
spend about five hours six hours going
through data and specifically in a very
very detailed data and not just regular
count of data that we're talking about
very detailed data but the one thing I
did this year I changed it up i sat
there by the way that's a spa back there
he has a spa yeah I split a garden back
there tennis court back there movie
theater and office right over there his
office like 4,000 square feet really
nice property very very modern on the
inside secret spots anyways you know we
started off 250 people are in Durham at
Beverly Hills Hilton and I started off
by asking 29 questions that we went
through question after question after
question after question after question I
think by the time it was done at least
30% room had been in tears at one point
or another why because in order to
recreate yourself we're too often liking
way too many quotes on Instagram
way too many quotes we like where for me
a question makes you move more than a
quote makes you move so and it's the
season anyways it's the
where you got a lot of people wanting to
change a lot of people want makes you to
be a big year for them you got a lot of
people that want to make some big
decisions for themselves and they want
to go out there and do something they've
never done before
the the beginning stages of all of that
it's with you is with you asking the
right questions of yourself so after
four hours of us going through these
questions with everybody by the time I
was over with everybody's sitting there
saying oh my gosh you know I never
thought about it this way before
and then there's breakthroughs and the
last time when we have a party here with
two 300 people we catering we got food
we got all this other stuff that's
hanging out having a conversation Erica
say hello we're having all these
conversations with all these folks
breakthroughs are taking place when I
asked the question I said so tell me
what's the biggest takeaway from the
event you know what everybody said those
questions I said why he says because the
questions got me to get into a state
that I hadn't been in before it made me
think about things ask myself stuff I
hadn't done before and took me to
complete different stage so what have
you got going on right now whatever you
got your goals for 2020 right now if you
really want things to change for you if
you really want things to change for you
in 2020 start by asking the right
questions one right question can change
any body's life when I tell you
anybody's I mean anybody's life one
right question if a guy can live in a 78
million dollar house in Beverly Hills
and there's there's a ton of these
around here it tells you at one point he
dreamt about the possibilities of him
building a big business for himself and
he had three tiers of products
would be CVG he had one product that's
was for people that other check this out
pretty cool garden table back here with
that bamboo trees private area like this
is something that mattered so look at
the way you set it up over here house is
pretty cool really cool watch this white
spots hiding spots you got to see what
he's got set up over you're very very
interesting oh my gosh this is kind of
cool get away from everybody come sit
over here oh my gosh this is comfortable
and relaxing holy moly if a guy you
gonna look him up the founder BCBG if
you build a one and a half billion
dollar business and it started off with
him having a vision a dream it probably
started off with him asking questions
why not mean why can't I do it why can't
my last name experience something like
this and there was probably a time where
he did it would guess what here's how
you probably did it see what's around me
who's around me do you see anybody
around me
nobody's wrong listen listen to the
noise you see the reflection what are
you here a pump
do you hear anybody no I guarantee you
all of these guys that do something big
by themselves big with themselves in
their lives at one point we're by
themselves asking themselves defining
moment type of questions that change
their lives you may be by yourself right
now maybe it's time for you to kind of
step away from everybody and start
asking the right questions of yourself
in order for you to give birth to a new
identity that the world's gonna look at
you and say I don't recognize you know
you but it will start with you asking
right questions having said that my
voice is almost gone have a killer week
this week much love to you take care bye
bye